After me a diagnosis with cancer pea size in my thyroid, my thyroid doctor recommended
an ablation of the thyroid since I do not want to remove this thyroid.
Are you familiar with this treatment for thyroid cancer? So they're just going to basically
burn off that part of the cancer. I'm uncertain of doing that. Well, it's the less invasive
than having your entire thyroid gland. But it still may affect your thyroid's ability to produce
T3 and T4. Those are the thyroid hormones. And you might have to get on either supplemental
approach to help stimulate what's left of your thyroid gland to help produce better
or a... I would do that first before you go on the medication. Make sure that you're getting
when you're doing thyroid tests that you're running a proper thyroid test. So a proper thyroid test
T4, T3, and then three T4, three T3, and then you're running TSH and you're running
thyroid globulin antibodies and you're running reverse T3 and you're running TSH.
So make sure you're getting a full panel of exactly what's going on with your thyroid as far as
its ability to produce thyroid hormone because lots of doctors will just run TSH or just run T3,
T4, and TSH because it's cheaper and your insurance covers it. Make sure you ask for that full panel
because you need a good picture of what's going on. Many times after thyroid treatment of
population or removal, it's not uncommon that you end up with thyroid antibodies. That's the...
Oh, I said TSH there. I meant TPO antibodies. So that's the TPO antibodies and the
thyroid globulin antibodies. That is what is called Hashimoto disease with its hyper producing a
hyper response and hyper production of T3 that is called Graves disease. But most of the time,
it's Hashimoto's is going to produce a hyper response. To your producing, you're going to end up with
low thyroid and elevated TPO or thyroid globulin antibodies. If you want to learn a ton more about
that kind of stuff, that's why I made these courses. You could go to this course, the autoimmune course,
and there's a full module on Hashimoto Graves disease in thyroid. That might be very beneficial for you.
I was also diagnosed with thyroiditis. Thyroiditis is inflammation of the thyroid. Still not telling
us why. It's a good idea if I don't know why. I will say that any problems with the thyroid. This is a
good to know. I don't have thyroid issues. If you have cancer, your friend has thyroid issues.
So many people have thyroid issues. You know somebody has thyroid issues. You have thyroid issues
of any kind. Even if you don't have Hashimoto's, I just have primary hypothyroidism. I mean,
you don't have elevated antibodies just to have low forebugs and maybe you're taking a supplement for
that. Maybe you're taking a medication for that. If you have any thyroid issues, you have to stay
off of gluten. So, gluten is what's in different foods. Wheat, dry, millet, and spelt. So,
gluten is something you have to stay away from. Gliannid is the protein in gluten. Gliannid is the
molecular matrix of the thyroid gland. So, if you stay eating gluten and you have thyroid problems,
you are going to have Hashimoto's. You're going to develop TPO or thyroid globular antibodies.
And it makes it more difficult to deal with. So, you got to stay out of gluten. So, with thyroid
issues, you have to make sure you're staying off of gluten. So, the thyroiditis, we still don't know what
the cause of the thyroiditis is. So, thyroiditis means you have inflammation of the thyroid,
doesn't tell us why. So, you have to get some further investigation of that.